[Applaus]
[Musik]
das besondere ist im grunde dass es
nicht eine klassische musiker
erfolgsgeschichte erzählt also die
karriere eines musikers nachzeichnet
sondern eben er diese großen fragen der
identität auf macht wer bin ich wohin
gehöre ich was will ich repräsentieren
[Musik]
es geht um den film tango mania die aus
gelangt kommt und mit ihrer familie im
alter von neun jahren vor dem
bürgerkrieg flüchteten
[Musik]
der regisseur des stephen law it hat in
erster linie mit privatem filmmaterial
gearbeitet aber er hat sich früh für
film interessiert und hat dann
irgendwann angefangen noch lange bevor
sie bekannt wurde
ihre geschichten ihre lebensgeschichte
im grunde in bildern festzuhalten ist
übrigens ein ehemaliger kommilitone von
und vielleicht hat das auch so ein
bisschen mit dieser persönlichen
beziehung zu tun die sie miteinander
haben dass da so dass sehr intimes
daraus entstanden ist
[Musik]
man muss immer ähnlich kennen und ihre
musik nicht also noch nicht besonders
viel mit ihrer musik zu tun gehabt haben
um diesen film doch mit mit begeisterung
oder mit mit interesse zu verfolgen
man sollte sich nur so ein bisschen für
die geschichte sri lankas interessieren
für die widerstandsbewegung dort
[Musik]
und man sollte was ein rüpelhaften
weiblich im rap
emma ist eben eine künstlerin die stark
mit ihrer migrationserfahrung arbeitet
also sie kommt nach england fühlt sich
dort immer wieder ausgegrenzt und
bezieht dann diese all diese erfahrungen
die sie dort macht in ihre in ihr
künstlerisches schaffen ein und ihre
musik ist nie nie unpolitisch
in things happen möglich sie macht es
auch eine sehr sehr ironische teilweise
auch selbstironische und starke das ist
eine sehr starke persönlichkeit und mit
dieser starken persönlichkeit geht es
diesen menschen dann durchaus auch mal
auf die nerven was man in diesem film
immer wieder feststellt aber sie macht
eben auch diesen grandiosen red habe ich
[Musik]
für eine innere spannung in diesem film
sorgt ist eben dass man sich natürlich
auch fragen welche szenen sind eben
nicht in den film gekommen und welche
geschichten wurden nicht erzählt und wo
es gegebenenfalls auch an der
mythenbildung ihrer person anteil gehabt
wer spaß an hiphop hat sollte sich
diesen film auf jeden fall anschauen
[Musik]
ja